hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and I'm just checking in on you
just checking in on you see now your
weeks going how's your week going huh
did your [__] team have another
championship parade like mine did well
you know what I wish it did why the [__]
should Mike town have all the goddamn
success you know it's [__]
unbelievable I still can't believe you
won that [__] game but I'm not gonna
go on and on and on and on and on and on
and on and on and on and on about it I'm
in Charlotte North Carolina came in a
day before the comedy zone gig I went to
the Charlotte Hornets versus the
Brooklyn Nets you know and when you try
to go to a home game sorry I'm gonna I
don't have my [__] microphone so I'm
just recording but if my laptop so any
time I click on something might be
goddamn issue but when you're trying to
do what it is that I've been doing which
is to basically go to all of the to go
to a home game of every [__] team in
all four major sports every once in a
while you got to go to a game it's not
the best game you got to go see a couple
of franchises that even though they've
had their moments this is not their time
they are they're currently rebuilding
and that's what that's what happened
when we saw the Charlotte Hornets play
the Brooklyn Nets a couple nights ago
Jesus Christ
it was it was just like it was I don't
know I don't know what it was it was
like a [__] WNBA game WNBA at its
worst in the first couple of seasons you
know where they just didn't look good I
mean they look way better now the
fundamentals and all that if he's watch
any the WNBA but those first few years I
couldn't understand why it looked so bad
because women's college basketball look
better than the WNBA but Jesus Christ
Charlotte first Brooklyn Jewish but I
say that enough time older ages this is
how [__] boring that game was the
kids that played at halftime was [__]
more exciting because they were running
the court big smiles on their faces was
[__] hilarious the game was like
something like you know 16 to 14 and it
was all layups and
just all [__] running the court
layups was tremendous and but anyways
last night we went to you know we worked
the comedy zone and I did the smartest
thing I've ever done on the road in a
long time was when the show was over I
just went home and I went to [__] bed
because the Charlotte Brooklyn night you
know I had a couple of pops about 17 and
the next day woke up I'm like but what
the what am i doing what the [__] am i
doing okay I got a newborn at home I
can't get any goddamn sleep I'm on the
road now I should be like a like a
[__] sober as a Churchmouse and just
go right to bed and that's what I did
last night
[__] phenomenal other than the
goddamn [__] cleaning lady's coming
by every 10 minutes yeah they didn't
this place I'm staying it doesn't have
the [__] off side so they just keep
coming housekeeping I love how they
[__] knock right housekeeping and
then immediately open the goddamn door
they said that there's a the lost art of
knocking on a door waiting for a
response and then coming in somewhere
along the line these goddamn kids today
oh yeah I just said that these goddamn
kids they think the fact they just
knocked that they could just means they
can then enter the room you knock you
wait for somebody say you know hang on a
second or bla bla bla bla bla
you don't just knock on a [__] door
and walk in you got to give the person
the chance you know put their dick away
or something you know who knows what
they're doing
maybe they're just sitting there in
their underwear right I don't [__]
know she [__] knock and you wait and
then you enter sorry I'm just saying
[__] can't stand that's one of my pet
peeves and lice people knock and then
they just [__] walk it that [__] or
if you know when you go into a parking
spot you know where two cars could fit
and you just stick your [__] [__] car
right in the middle of both so no one
can fit two cars can't fit anymore
unless you're driving a smart car
so anyways tonight
you probably think Jesus built after
that Patriots Super Bowl how could your
sport
how could you sports world get any
better you don't it mean well after a
major dip I believe on Monday which I
think they did on purpose cuz the Bruins
had a little gap in their schedule and
with all the buzz about doing the
Patriots excuse we have your dick here
be a good time to get rid of cloak
Julian and I just want to thank coach
Julian for being the best Bruins coach
since I've been watching them for the
last you know close to 40 years
Jason Spurs everybody hey buzzy I'm
doing my podcast this is the Thursday
one like it'll be done like a half-hour
you go eat those eggs and then I'll meet
you first team anyway [__] don't [__]
was I talking about
yeah Chloe Julia of Jesus Christ I've
never seen a guy more of a victim of the
GM and for the I do not understand that
[__] move
whatsoever you know I guess maybe if he
had a falling out with the people up top
I have no idea but how you just gonna
blame it on him and not get rid of your
[__] Jim I don't know what they see
in this our GM I have no [__] idea I
don't know I have no idea what this guy
is doing I mean he got rid of everybody
and I just didn't I don't see you yeah
we actually were playing our best hockey
of the year I felt you know we went
three in a row
lost a tough one of the [__] Capitals
not a tough one they actually kicked our
ass fired or two but I mean what the
[__] they're the Capitals we didn't do
bad for a seven seed I know I think it's
a dumb move you get rid of the guy
like okay you want to get rid of the guy
who are you gonna replace him with who's
out there you know and actually tweeted
congratulations to every year every
other NHL team out there that needs a
[__] coach that knows how to win a
cup because that's what we just dumped I
don't know I don't know I don't get the
[__] that stuff where the ownership
gives into the fan base it's like what
are they listening to the [__] dopes
that call into sports talk radio I've
never called in a sports talk i watch
sports all the [__] time I would
never call in a sports talk radio show
you know just specifically to talk about
the sports thing I mean I'm calling into
hyper show you know pour myself out oh I
would absolutely do that
no speaking of whoring myself out
wait wait wait let me get back so thank
you to Claude Julien and uh bringing us
a Stanley Cup and and in a you know 40
year drought and continued success
wherever you go I know you're gonna do
great wherever you go hopefully you got
a better GM at the next place you go to
so anyways after all my ranting and
raving about award shows I think I might
be a presenter at one Oh Hollywood built
is the Writers Guild Awards and they
asked me to be a presenter or whatever
at first was like that I'm not gonna go
down and do that [__] [__] but
then you know what I'm actually I guess
soften enough or selling out depends on
how you look at it but what I realize is
that on our show
it's those award shows are a big deal
for for the writers because that's how
they actually get money so if you win an
Emmy or a Writers Guild or a SAG thing
or whatever it's great for the writers
in the writers room because they can say
that they wrote on an Emmy award-winning
show and bla bla bla bla bla so old
freckles has to play the game a little
bit
go put on a goddamn monkey suit it's a
[__] black tie thing I gotta go I'm
gonna go to one of those [__] prom
places where they have the cheap tuxedos
because I don't think anybody can
[__] tell just come out in those
goddamn plastic bowling shoes I don't
know who the [__] decided that they
wanted me to be a [__] percenter but
like if they've never they've obviously
never listened to me read out loud on my
podcast but uh I don't know I figured
this would be a good one to try out see
what I think about it because it's not
televised you know and I don't know
we'll see if I can actually read out
loud I don't know Mia's been on me about
this [__] you gotta do it you gotta play
the game all right
I'm playing the [__] game why make a
[__] difficult business even more
goddamn difficult so [__] it I'll give
it a job but you guys know how that goes
how am i reading out loud if that's what
in fact what they have me to but it's
not bad it's only like two hours long so
it kind of seems like the best one to go
to and Patton Oswalt is hosting it I
think he's a [__] genius so at least
I'll get to listen to his monologue that
I'm without a doubt I'm gonna get the
[__] I'm gonna get a nice [__] I'm
gonna get a senior prom special the clip
on [__] tie and all of that [__]
that's like the dumbest [__] ever to go
out and go buy some expensive tuxedo
it's like what are you a [__]
rockefeller but I guess people trash it
then right when you watch the walk the
red carpet or something like that so
anyway so there you go this my foolish
[__] moment after making fun of all
those [__] award shows I'm actually
gonna go to one I don't what are you
gonna do the [__] am I gonna do right
I'm doing it for the team okay can I get
out of it by saying that so anyways I
was saying um how my my my sporting
world how it could get any better after
the the Patriots win and then they the
letdown of seeing them give into the fan
pressure whatever the [__] they did
getting rid of
Julian tonight me furs e and Joe Bartnik
are doing a bucket list thing for any
person that's even remotely into sports
were going to the the Duke versus North
Carolina Tar Heels game tonight
and we got some great seats we're
sitting right behind the [__] Duke
bench
Coach K's gonna be there if it wasn't so
goddamn loud in that place we could hear
him you know during the timeouts and
everything it's gonna be crazy so I
don't know it's a chance you might see
the three three of us dummies on TV but
beyond excited to go to this like this
is a there's a [__] huge one this is
a huge one as far as the bucket list
sports stuff to go two years ago I told
you I don't know if I told you guys I
went to the I went to Indiana University
versus was it Michigan State and I
believe lose the year the Michigan State
won the national championship and Bobby
Knight was still coaching there and I've
never seen anything like that all the
years everything I've ever every
sporting event I've ever gone to I have
never seen anything like watching Bobby
Knight coach a game I mean that guy you
watched him more than as much if not
more than you were watching the game I
was actually rooting for the Spartans
you know I came there rooting for
Indiana but bobby was so [__]
entertaining I started rooting for the
Spartans because I wanted to see him
flip out even more I've never seen
somebody with yes he made me feel good
about myself like just complete loss of
composure o or whatever his coaching
style motivating people I remember they
let up a couple of easy buckets and this
kid the point guard starts bringing it
up the court and Bobby Knight it's like
10 feet onto the court and he's yelling
so much he's like Jeff sieh was at Ben
Kingsley in sexy beast
2020 when he's yelling you being a right
[__] and he's like throwing his head
to everything that he was saying that's
what the [__] he was doing but it was
way more intense because he wasn't
acting he was serious and I've never
[__] seen anything like that that's
one of my favorite of everything that
I've seen in sports the coolest thing
ever is that I got to see Bobby Knight
coach in Indiana University Matt's
[__] legend that's like seeing
Zeppelin we're seeing the Beatles you
know James Brown or whatever like you
know that's right up there I saw Eddie
Murphy on the rod tour I saw Eddie
please Mike but think greatest things
I've seen Eddie Murphy on the rod tour I
saw 20 with a purple suit I saw Bobby
Knight coach Indiana the [__] they go
from there so Judas Priest in the turbo
lover torch does that count
I know I saw Stevie Ray Vaughan I saw
Dan Marino kick the [__] out of the
Patriots with Don Shula coaching that's
the one great thing about being our old
guys you can start talking about all
this [__] since I note that now [__]
no longer exists so I actually made a
few guys who just bear with me clicking
here sorry I know that's [__] loud as
hell I know it's annoying and you're
gonna listen to it again right now
all right I actually looked through I
got this this document team scene and I
have seen 31 I've been to a home game of
every major league baseball team
I haven't been to all this stadiums
because like the Mets changed there's
got a new one Phillies got a new one but
I've seen a total of 31 there's 30
professional baseball teams I've seen 31
because I went to the Expos I've seen 32
home games of the NFL there's 32 teams
but I still need to see the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers they're the last one I need
to see but I saw the st. Louis and the
[__] the st. Louis and the [__]
[Music]
LA Rams so that's how I got up to 32
I've seen 25 NBA teams one of those
being the I saw both the Seattle Sonics
and the Oklahoma City Thunder and I saw
the New Jersey Nets now I got to go see
the [__] Brooklyn that's speaking of
which I also saw the [__] would I see
the [__] the Islanders at Nassau
Coliseum now if they don't if they don't
become the Brooklyn [__] Islanders
then then I don't need to go see him
it's like if you change it they're still
in New York you know what I mean I don't
[__] do that so I've seen 27 of the
30 [__] I got three more to see in in
hockey so I'm gonna try to knock those
out over the next year the fan slam is
what I'm calling it you know you know
Serena's [__] the Serena slam this is
just a fan slam the [__] you know you
have no life you run the [__] road
you don't want to kill yourself in a
comedy condo so you start building it
around home games that actually made a
list I don't know if you're not a sports
fan this is gonna bore the [__] out of
you but these are all the [__] places
I've been to that now no longer exist
the Boston Garden
Sullivan Stadium Yankee Stadium Shea
Stadium Veterans Stadium Three Rivers
Stadium soon to be no longer there Joe
Louis Arena the RCA / Hoosier dome
I saw peyton manning there i saw a game
at original Soldier Field got a picture
and then this [__] [__] stole my
goddamn camera I was at a picture of me
and when I went to a Green Bay Packers
then I came was a was a preseason game
he played the Browns Brett fiber it was
still there mercy says I can't count
that one cuz it's preseason but the
reality is is you just wants me to book
you know book a get like the skyline
cafe and go to a Packers game which of
course I will do all right
continuing on County Stadium to the
Target Center the Metrodome the Edward
Jones Dome which is still there
but the st. Louis Rams don't play there
anymore Texas Stadium the Astrodome
McNichols Arena Mile High Stadium Sun
Devil Stadium that still exists but I
saw the Arizona Cardinals first the
Patriots their Qualcomm Stadium still
exists but the [__] charges aren't
there anymore I also saw that the San
Diego Padres there and I went there with
and watch Mark McGwire take batting
practice the year he broke Roger Maris's
record and I saw him hit number 27 or 28
there Edison field before they redid it
LA the LA sports arena that's still
there but I saw who did I see there I
saw the Clippers there I saw the
Clippers there and Biggie Smalls was in
the crowd and four days later he was
dead swear to God the LA forum
I saw [__] a young Kobe Bryant and
just left the magic Shack with Dell
Harris as a coach I want to say Dennis
Rodman was on that team I went to
Candlestick Park sat out in right field
and saw a early on head getting bigger
Barry Bonds Key Arena for a seattle
supersonics game with rookie year kevin
durant and then the Kingdome i saw a
young ken griffey jr. i sat right out in
centerfield bleachers and as far as I
know oh you know what else the the
Montreal Forum I can't believe I forgot
that I saw the mantra 1989 I went up
there in March and I saw Canadians
versus the [__] Minnesota North Stars
with Patrick Juan net I of course rooted
for the North Stars and they of course
lost so whatever that's that's the dumb
[__] that I do when I'm out here on
the road and now I can add the after
tonight duke-carolina and I want to
thank the comedy zone for hooking us up
with some sort of do booster that gave
us those tickets and I was surprised the
person came to the game line came to the
game came to the show last night and
left without saying hello
which was
it's like at least gotta thank the guy
so if he's listening or she's listening
whatever the [__] it is it got me the
tickets thank you so much and with that
let's listen to me try to read out loud
as I practice for an award show the
nominees for the best kiss in a [__]
movie about or nocta puss all right loot
crate everybody give me the loot
speaking of Biggie Smalls rest his soul
be the envy of your friends and get you
a 100% exclusive crates at loot crate
calm / / and enter my code barfi you are
are to save $3 off on any new
subscription crush that first sentence
wait until I tell you about February's
crate
it is very put together I [__] that
one up copy points mention at least
three ton times spot doctor sent me on a
quest for epic gear housewares and
collectibles loot crate has it the best
surprises you know was coming blue crate
offers an epic focus text to me alright
if you're more of a fantastical
fashionista and I'm gonna bomb at this
[__] thing then try loot where
monthly wearables and accessories with
coke classics and your favorite
franchises if you want to get fancy get
a bigger box with even bigger loop with
Luke do it loot crate DX want to geek
out your pet try loot pets there what
dude I don't know this is like the [__]
is insane you just go buy all these
crazy t-shirts about [__] movies and
put them all over any living thing if
you're if you got a goldfish try a loot
fish scuba where alright get ready get
over a little Aquaman [__] outfit get
ready for the pop culture themed
February's pop culture faint build loot
crate has an awesome and exclusive items
from the most put together franchises
this February experienced iconic items
from Mighty Morphin I don't know what
that is power ranges Batman Lego
dimensions and Tetris including as
always our monthly t-shirt and pin go to
loot crate calm / fur and enter my code
burn save three dollars off any new
subscription today
holy [__] this is perfect for the award
show the black tux looking great for a
wedding or a special event has never
been easier with the black tux calm I'm
[__] doing this with high quality
rental suits then I got to measure
myself don't I what a [__] do you do
that you gotta use your chin right drunk
and hold the thing down with the high
quality Reynolds suits and tuxedos
delivered to your doorstep the black tux
is giving guys a new way to rent and get
this the black tux offers free home try
on so you can see the fit and feel the
quality on your suit months before your
event like up days the best part it's
complimentary done online no trips to
the tuck shop required alright any when
it does it twice I saw it the [__]
first time the black tux calm you lets
you create your loot your look your loot
crate your look or choose from tons of
styles stylistic selected outfits
starting at just 95 bucks that's the
kind of tux I'm looking for these suits
have a modern fit and are made from the
from fine Italian wool itchy the highest
quality on the rail market and if you
have any questions or issue their expert
customer care team has your back every
step of the way after ordering your suit
will arrive 14 days before the event
that's a full two weeks to try it on to
make sure everything fits anything is
less than perfect the black tux will
send you a free replacement right away
when your events over you just dropped a
rental back in the mail shipping is free
both ways how easy is that to get
started now visit the black tux calm
slash for an experience a new way to
rent that's the black tux calm slash bar
alright I'm getting exhausted just
[__] reading blue apron
hey everybody not all ingredients are
created equal man fresh high-quality
ingredients make a real difference so
it's important to know where your food
comes from talk about how it feels to
cook for yourself oh my god first of all
what I love most about it is I can do it
in the nude you know it's my kitchen if
I pull the blinds who gives a [__] right
you know I put on an apron you know it's
kind of like when you're completely
naked cooking with an apron on that's
kind of like that's the kitchens version
of chaps
each meal comes with a step-by-step
easy-to-follow recipe card and
pre-portioned ingredients and can be
prepared in 40 minutes the left less
blue aprons freshness guaranteed
promises that every ingredient in your
delivery arrives ready to cook
although make it right customize your
recipes each week based on your [__]
preferences blue apron has several
delivery options so you can choose what
fits your needs and there's no weekly
commitment so you only get deliveries
when you want them check out this week's
menu and get your first your first three
meals for free with free shipping by
going to blue a 4.com slash / you will
love how good it feels and tastes to
create an incredible incredible
home-cooked meals with blue apron so
don't wait the blue apron that's blue
apron calm / / blue apron a better way
to cook I like those guys you know
they're giving you a healthy food and
they only make me say their website one
time alright lastly but certainly not
least distilled jeans great jeans just
don't have to be complicated if you're
not into crazy stitching diamonds and
embedded studs you're not alone you know
it's funny you know what if I come dad
jeans now guys who became dads in like
the last 10 years there's those True
Religion ones that add like that
horseshoe stitching on the [__] back
I saw a couple guys at the airport
wearing those and they had like kids and
[__] they're all faded you know the dumb
white stitching down the side I didn't
even buy those things those things from
from day one look like some country
singer [__] right
alright distilled pronounce distilled
offers luxury great denim at an
affordable price jeans that would
normally cost you hundreds to still has
just starting at 75 bucks you know what
they sent me a pair of them they're
really [__] nice they utilized the
same fabrics and factories and wash
houses as the best-known brands and
designs while skipping the markups in
the middlemen the result pure
unadulterated denim with real retail
without the retail runaround just go to
distilled calm spelled EST l d.com
and see
we're minimus designs meets maximum
comfort they guarantee the fit they'll
ship them for free and give you free
items of return until you find the
perfect pair I'll give you free return
sorry this still has been featured in
Forbes times at TechCrunch as well as on
denim clad celebrities and GQ and folk
distill is the only place in the u.s.
you can get this quality denim for this
price you can find their amazing
selections of outerwear leather jackets
t-shirts and more using the same
principles of high-grade materials at
low in cost even celebrities are wearing
distill I got a pair of the name the
Jean style and the fit is perfect they
did give me a pair of jeans I don't know
what style it is and yeah they hug my
junk pretty nicely this still is your
answer to elevate style without elevated
prices just go to distilled com slash
for right now and get 10% off your first
pair that's D STL decom slash burger for
10% off right now
that the five letters D STL d.com slash
birth all right that's Delta Sierra
tango Lima Delta all right let's get
back to the top of the patron finished
us out all right as I've been a half an
hour I have no idea I never know
whenever I'm [__] recording on just
the GarageBand thing here so we're gonna
go to the game here tonight I can't
believe I'm gonna see them be this close
to [__] coach K I know Duke's having
a tough time this year but Coach K's
back from back surgery and he did that
thing where he I guess every once in a
while I get so disgusted with his team
he doesn't let him wear any do gear and
he won't let him in the locker room
until they start playing at a [__]
level that the university is used to see
you gotta love that old-school coaching
that made me look up like you know
looking up all this stuff on Coach K and
I didn't realize that when he was at
Army he played for Bobby Knight I didn't
know that he assisted with Bobby Knight
and all
there's all these great [__] pictures
you got to see the way Bobby Knight is
dressed in 1979 in Puerto Rico when he's
at the Pan Am Games
of course he ended up getting arrested
because he allegedly slapped a cop or
something like that you want to talk
about a guy that needs to [__]
meditate Jesus Christ so anyways I was
watching all the stuff where his course
sent me down this rabbit hole with Bobby
Knight stuff and you know my favorite
clip of all the Bobby Knight ones was
when somebody secretly recorded him cuz
I feel like that was the real Bobby
Knight as I thought towards the end he
kind of was was doing the Bobby Knight
thing like when he did that game face
thing I think at that point he was just
he started like hamming it up when he
didn't need to but like when you listen
to that one where he's talking about the
Purdue game coming up and that he has an
8 and 10 record I swear to god I'm gonna
start listening bet speech before I go
to the gym because I actually listen
that thing and he's talking about how he
had to go to some function and he goes
I'm sick now I'm tired to sit there with
a [__] 8 and 10 record everything
[__] look ii [__] tired [__] do
you guys get the [__] out there says
somebody if you [__] lose to purdue
he put me in that [__] position I
will [__] run you and something until
you I don't know something about puking
or whatever it's it's just such a great
speech and then the end of it my natural
reaction I laughed and just said that's
how it's done
and I know we got a lot of criticism for
the stuff that he did but I think a lot
of that criticism came from people that
are not athletic were never in a locker
room and you know they came from that
hole they they actually had bad
experiences in sports and listening to
Bobby Knight yell I think just brought
all their sucking in gym class memories
back and I don't know it's like this
this a certain type of person that is a
[__] athlete and can handle that and
understand
what the [__] that is and I think if
they don't have a problem with it all
these people who don't play sports
should just shut the [__] up about it
because you don't understand what's
going on and I mean Jesus Christ Bobby
Knight won almost a thousand [__]
games and all his former players for the
most part loved them and and I always
felt that kid that last [__] incident
that Bobby Knight had I thought that
felt that kid was baiting him because
Bobby Knight walked by and I think the
kid said what's up Knight you don't say
that that's totally disrespectful and I
just had that that [__] temper of
zero to [__] 9000 but I mean when I
heard that stories like that kid was
being a [__] [__] but he can't do
that [__] anymore
at least during his heyday there was no
cell phone cameras man he really would
have gotten a lot of trouble because it
would have been [__] video of that
and I would have loved every second I
would have loved every second of
watching him grab some student by the
[__] throat who just said what's up
night guys walking around nine hundred
[__] wins some sophomore comes by and
that's come on so anyways yeah so we're
gonna be hitting that game tonight
if anybody knows oh by the way I have to
give a shout-out man I went to a this is
my new thing now and I'm on the road you
know cuz I got my beautiful little
daughter at home and I can't play drums
as much you know Nia still lets me
rehearse and stuff like that you know
not rehearse like practice and [__] when
I when I'm home if the kids up but I
haven't been able to go to a you know
the practice place that I go to out in
LA as much as I would like so much when
I'm on the road out or look up these
rehearsal spaces so I looked up this
place when I was in Charlotte it's
called the playground and I went down
there shout-out to Ed easy who runs it
totally [__] one of the coolest dudes
I've met a lot of these rehearsal spaces
are just absolute [__]
the drum kits are old everything's
[__] up everything
sounds like [__] I went in since places
place was like a [__] first-class
place he stuck me in the best room that
they had at a discount price because
they were doing construction on some
other rooms and he didn't want them you
don't disturb me or whatever while I was
playing I played for like [__] three
hours well I paid for three hours only
to get to about you know two hours and
twenty minutes and my body was like
giving out on me and I just had the best
[__] time and you know what I loved
when I went in there the snare drum was
tuned to low and I was able to tune it
up to sound pretty good and I used to
not even remotely have a game plan on
how to tune up the snare and I was
really psyched about that thank you
but anyways this guy Eddie Z was saying
he actually used to be a roadie for Van
Halen and he was on the 1984 tour the
last one with David Lee Roth and then he
did a couple with Sammy Hagar so we had
all these [__] really cool pictures
just originals that he took of like
Sammy and Eddie Van Halen and Dave Lee
Roth was really [__] cool and I had
the best time and like that's gonna be
on song I'm gonna do when I'm on the
road now that I'm back building up the
hour working the comedy clubs like the
old days at such a great time last night
on stage comedy zone 2 comedy songs one
of the best [__] comedy clubs out
there by the way if you can find the
goddamn thing you got a take you walk in
there's like a cafeteria than a bar and
there's there's a sign that says comedy
zone and nobody tell you got a like ass
like 20 people on it's like you're
feeling your way through the dark to
finally go down those stairs to go down
there but just the hallway this the
stage is set up it seems like every seat
in the house is a good seat
you know footmen obviously I've never
sat in the crowd out there but uh just
had the best time working the [__] out I
did two shows both shows I was able to
do a little over an hour just pasting
together new ideas that I have and then
old bits that you know never made it
onto specials and just thought oh this
is bliss you wouldn't think so this is
one of my favorite
doing stand-up is just letting
everything else go and just trying to
figure out like what the new shits gonna
be you know I'm reading newspapers I'm
writing [__] down anything that I can
throw against the wall last night I was
on stage talking about how [__] human
beings are edible like and everyone was
like what the [__] and that'd be
something that I would abandon but I had
no material I just kept going with it
and I don't know it just takes me back
to my early days I'll stand up when
because your skills like if you don't
have the material it just complete your
skills completely diminish even though
you have the poise and and the skill set
because you've been doing it that long
but it's just completed just remember
imagine a band if they had to like just
work at workshops some riffs in front of
a [__] crowd without like rehearse
and that's the greatest thing about the
art of stand-up comedy is that you can't
you can't go to a rehearsal space and
get the [__] together and then [__]
like you have to second you like coming
up with riffs in front of the [__]
crowd and it's yeah it's [__] work
it's absolute work but uh I don't know
I'm a [__] lunatic so I totally enjoy
this part of it so anyways that is the
podcast once again thanks to whoever it
is that owns these two seats whoever
that is get in touch with the comedy
zone you have free tickets to any comedy
show that I ever do for life
front row whatever the [__] you want
forgiven giving up these tickets can't
thank you enough this is gonna be
amazing so we're on our way up to Durham
and I was just out there so I know a
couple of good spots to eat at so we're
gonna have a good time all right that's
the podcast go [__] yourselves have a
great weekend you [__] and I will talk
to you I'll talk to you on Monday
like I'll let you know about the game
alright
[Music]
hey what's up this is Dilbert
and this is the Monday morning podcast I
just did a 50 minute podcast by trying
to save it and didn't once again this
week talked for a [__] hour evidently
to nobody I'm gonna have to buy some
sort of device so I can save them so I
can try and put them back up I don't
know what to tell you
but I don't know if this one's gonna
record I don't know if I'm going to long
I don't even know who the [__] I'm
supposed to call who the [__] do I call
it's not like I call this number on
anybody you can talk to picks up you
know typical of how we're living you
know I was on the [__] airplane
flying out to Boston right I'm on the
airplane and for some reason they always
have to [__] intercoms turned all the
way up to 10 right hello is my goddamn
eardrums out so I say the lady she walks
by I go is there any way you can turn
the thing down she's like now I sigh
there's nothing we can do [__] do you
mean there's nothing you can do you can
go up there you can [__] turn it down
whatever they installed an intercom
system on 10 with no [__] volume
whatever [__] this technology [__] I got
to figure out somebody sent me an email
about something that I can record into
I'm gonna try to find that I guess I got
to go out and buy it but I apologize I'm
gonna try to do one again tomorrow with
something like that oh Jesus it was such
a great podcast god damn it alright
whatever I'm going to try tomorrow
so all 14 of you hang in there and do a
podcast tomorrow all right take it easy
you
[Music]
hey what's up this is bill burr I don't
know what the [__] is wrong with this G
cast thing but I have figured out how to
save my podcast all that it was present
number two for some reason I wasn't
hearing that you know I don't know she
was saying it or whatever the computer
with the [__] female voice and it's
been saying it but I don't know what's
going on with this thing it seems
anytime I record something longer than I
don't know what doesn't [__] go
through but I know how to save them so
all I'm saying is from here on out I
won't lose any more podcast but I'm
going to do a podcast tomorrow and I'm
going to save the thing and hopefully I
can publish it alright thank you for
your patience and God bless the United
States of America
[Music]
hey what's going on its bill bird it is
the Monday morning podcast mama said
Claude the Monday morning podcast
Long Island at 6:18 on a [__]
Wednesday and I learned how to save
these podcasts and here you go this is
the podcast this is it I'm doing one
take I don't give a [__] I've already
done three times and I'm running a red
light
and I made it good deal good deal oh hey
you guys you guys got cameras you got
cameras where you're at you know you run
a red light and they take your [__]
picture and then for some reason you
have to pay the [__] ticket I got a
way around it I got a way around it that
I've learned
somebody told me all you got to do when
you run the red light you got to be in
the center
you know if there's two lanes just be in
the middle have half your car in one
lane after your car in the other Lane
and that doesn't get your pole license
plate or your full face and you through
it granted
I haven't tried that yet but I heard you
can do that also is another way when I
got my car out here and lost on delays
evidently evidently there's so many
[__] people out here that uh that you
know it takes I swear to god it took
like four weeks or six weeks for me to
get my license plate something
ridiculous so basically I drove around
for well over a month with just the name
of the dealership where I bought my car
at on both the front in the back and one
day as luck would have it I was like
going to the airport and I ran a [__]
red light and they took my picture and I
flipped out I was like ah [__] you know
that's me flipping out that [__] see I
stink it acting that's good bill could
you raise the stakes you wanted I really
did I was like you gotta be [__]
kidding me this is [__] [__]
that's what I really did but I don't
want to yell like that and but basically
all they had was the picture the
dealership my stupid face
so I never got the ticket why am i
admitting to this can they use this in a
court of law
come and get me say Wow
so anyways I'm driving down the street
and I don't have my laptop with me so I
don't have your questions but God knows
I read them enough times that I can
actually remember them once so here's
the first question somebody asked me hey
Bill
what kind of drum kit do you have and
will you have it in a band and if so do
you have any good band stories all right
I have a late 70 Slingerland 5-ply the
Firefly shells that nobody wants
everybody wants to three-ply shells from
the late sixties early seventies to get
that great tone whatever the [__]
they're talking about well fortunately
I'm a comedian so I don't give a [__]
I'll text it I'll take the extra two
plies and basically they're all bottom
sizes 14 by 24 bass drum I had a 13
number 13 it's 14 and then an 18 inch
floor time so years later I bought the
16 inch floor time and recently I had
another bass drum because I was
listening to the Primus and I was like I
want to play like Tim Alexander even
though I already had a double pedal I'm
like I'm gonna add another bass drum
pedal because that guy from Slayer said
it's not the same unless you have the
[__] both of them so I went out and I
bought another bass drum and I should
have realized the fact that I sucked
with the double pedal that they added a
second bass drum all it was going to do
was just take up more room and it
wouldn't make me any better a drummer
but I did it so yeah that's what I play
I got an old slingerland kit and have I
ever been in a band no I was never in a
band I just had a [__] I didn't the
drums were at my house so everybody came
over to jam man and we sucked which is
why everybody whoever came over now has
a real job
yeah that's it I don't have any Rockstar
I don't even you [__] dance stories
other than that we stunk the usual [__]
and the next question somebody asked me
was uh what the [__] was the question it
was some question about I guess late at
night they got these new economy
dentures something like that that's what
the person asked me have you seen these
economy dentures what the [__] is this
and it's actually a really interesting
question because I used to work in a
dental office and I know a little subtle
about dentures huh look at me it's
peeling off another layer of the onion
as Madonna says you know she actually
had the balls to say that one time she
has no any balls God knows we've all
seen her [__]
yeah she actually have the nerve to say
that when she did yet another totally
planned out you know look I can dress
like a [__] this way nice [__]
parking job you [__] idiot
[__] I swear to god man people just you
know people cannot [__] drive out
here in LA they really can't like a lot
of people don't know that all they talk
about is the traffic oh my good it's
very picky so [__] bad man well you
know what when it clears up the driving
get then people can actually drive their
there I've established it before you
know they [__] they suck at driving
out here look at that homeless guy
there's a homeless guy out here I swear
to god he looks like George Clinton from
Parliament anybody so anyways you're
asking me what these economy dentures
are I'm gonna guess that they are a
one-size-fits-all denture which is
really [__] bizarre and I bet on the
upper it has some sort of form-fitting
thing that will fit to your palate it's
horrific because when you get a denture
you're actually supposed to you know
this impressions you pour up a model you
know if they took out some teeth they
try to get the teeth to look like your
other teeth so you don't freak people
out like one day you look like a witch
and the next day you come walking and
look like guys smiley you know I used to
work in a dental office actually I'm
certified to take x-rays I can take
impressions the upper impression was the
worst I'd always get some sell I'm just
gonna let you know that I'm a gag er I
gag really why don't you just brush your
[__] teeth so I have to worry about
you throwing up on the [__]
left sleeve of my mic what would he call
is the doctor robe the doctor coat or
whatever yeah I used to take the
impressions and people used to always
gag oh when you do the top and if you
hang in there another eight seconds cool
and then they always have then they
always say yeah I got I like [__]
hate the dentist really well why don't
you brush your [__] teeth you idiot
you know I guess I do the same thing I
ain't going to the gym but God knows I'm
gonna go order a [__] pizza right now
oh Jesus I'm in a mood so yeah that's
what I would get so basically after you
took the impressions if you want to know
the whole [__] process and the
person's going to lose
every five seconds if they don't puke on
you you actually have a good impression
then you take it into the little lab and
then you take out a little green cup
that rubber green cup that's all I
remember things can only be mixed in
that I never took a chemistry class so I
don't know why it couldn't be just a
plastic bowl but it was always those
rubber things and then you'd mix it up
and then you'd pour it into the [__]
impression and then you'd stick it on
this little vibrating thing trying to
get all the bubbles out of it there was
nothing [__] worse if you didn't get
all the bubbles out of it and then I
swear to god the bubble would always be
right where that person's tooth was and
you'd [__] up the whole impression and
then you'd have to go in there and be
like we got to do it again oh I'd have
to deal with that again so I would guess
that what they're doing is is they
they're skipping that whole step I don't
know what they do if you take a whole
pack of juicy fruit and you chew it up
and then you know form it to the top of
your mouth and then you mail that in and
they make a denture out of that I have
no [__] idea but that's really a
that's really a scary thing it's a
really scary thing you know that's the
kind of [__] I wish people focused on
like everybody keeps talking about that
[__] broad with the eight kids can
you believe it I mean that's so
irresponsible who gives a [__] people
talking about all the money she's going
to cost us she's gonna cost us what a
couple million you know what about the
fee you know the [__] bankers
three-quarters of trillion dollars
nobody gives a [__] about that some
chick squirts eight babies out of her
[__] it's going to cost us you know one
half of one percent compared to what
these [__] [__] bid who stole a
trillion dollars and then gave
themselves thirty million dollar bonuses
nobody gives a [__] about that you know
some chick squirts out [__] eight
babies and all of a sudden no one can
stop looking at it you know why because
it has a face you know what she looks
like that's the thing that's the genius
for the bankers nobody knows what a
banker looks like I know what the [__]
my teller looks like I go to the goddamn
ATM because I work nights um all right
what else what else could I do on this
podcast this is going to be a short
podcast I'm doing a podcast until I get
home
and that's gonna be it because I'm
exhausted with these [__] podcasts
all right it's insane you know the
amount of podcasts that I've done this
[__] week and to no avail you know it
reminds me of listening to somebody
talking about who the [__] was it
recording with like Ray Charles you do
like nine nine thousand takes so George
off my mind by the end of it you wanted
to make them death too you know
that's why I feel like right now with
these [__] podcast so I guess the
last thing that I have to do is I'm
stuck in traffic waiting to make my left
hand turn to come home to order a pizza
is I going to nounce the winner of the
the submissions for the original
proctologist I went to the proctologist
joke I got a home it man they were all
strong and everybody seemed to like
there's sort of an even amount of people
like in every one of them except for one
so basically I think I'm going to pass
out like three or four DVDs you know you
know what everybody's a winner except
for the one guy the one guy on meandered
for 20 minutes about Kevin the chicks
titty matched in the mammogram he's the
only one who didn't get any votes
everybody else the guy with the potato
salad line got a lot of votes the dude
who's freaked me out got a bunch of
votes and the dude who did the had the
great angle I thought this was the most
original angle of the gay guy bragging
that he's dating a proctologist you know
if he didn't listen to that podcast he
would say like it's kind of like if you
know one of you one of your buddies
started dating a gymnast you know and
then then all your buddies would be
jealous like Jesus Christ I bet she can
do some freaky [__] you know you can
bend her every which way he was saying
gay guys would do that I bet they'd get
jealous if you started dating a
proctologist and they'd all be sitting
around going Jesus Christ I bet he
really knows his way around it ass thank
you that was the hacky gay guy voice I
don't you guys noticed but my chick
voice is basically the hacky gay guy
voice just done it a whisper if you ever
want to get that impression
down instead of going hi fellas I just
go hey what's going on where's this
relationship going
exact same thing I'm a complete [__]
no-talent and anyways I'm in my garage
right now so this podcast is over I know
it was a quick one I know it was a quick
one all right it's a little twelve
minutes it's an EP all right like Guns
and Roses lies that's what it's like
all right stuff I didn't drop the n-word
even though there was a half-black Obama
guitarist in my group how [__]
drugged up with slash that day where he
[__] co-signed on that one um anyway
I want to thank everybody who came out
to the my shows back in Boston at the
comedy connection at the Wilbur theater
and out in Chicopee Massachusetts I had
and I had a great time coming back there
had a bunch of friends family former
babysitter from the 70s showed up it was
a it was an unbelievable weekend and
then I went out to Chicopee
Massachusetts that show sold out as well
and I was a bunch of drunks and I made
my way through it and then I went back
to my fancy hotel in Boston
I ordered a filet mignon see the maid
had left classical music on the clock
radio trying to remember how this went
down that's why I walked into my hotel
room say you know the turndown service I
don't know what that means they fold
your sheets back and they give you a
mint and she left classical music
playing on my clock radio
I ordered the filet mignon little mashed
potatoes a glass of red wine and I sat
there and ate it and it was one of the
most loneliest experiences I've ever had
in my life to the point I actually had
to call Robert Kelley and tell him in
the moment how lonely I was the steak
sucked too I actually it was such a bad
steak I actually didn't even consider
putting a 1 on it I went straight to
catch up that's
how bad it was and I don't put anything
on you shouldn't put anything on a stake
it should just taste delicious and this
thing was so [__] I ordered it medium
rare and it was great all the way
through and it was tough like [__]
shoe leather that mozzarella anybody
know that I'm what's that went from
anybody I'll give you five seconds tough
like [__] shoe leather that
mozzarella I only know one other [__]
person who ever knew that reference
whoever brought it up and he owns Gotham
comedy club it was uh Eric Roberts in
the Pope of Greenwich Village tough like
[__] shoe leather that move to Rome
anyway the [__] stakes stunk and I
actually put ketchup on it I like it
literally take it tasted like [__]
hamburger
no it didn't cuz hamburger tastes great
but you know to me any chefs out there
you never put ketchup okay let's do
overrated underrated you know what's
[__] overrated a one steak sauce I
don't even get it it it's just
it sucks I am in a garage right now
talking to myself basically about
[__] a1 steak sauce who gives a [__]
I'm done with this podcast next week
you're gonna get you're gonna get a
double album out of me alright I promise
you but this week to get in the EP
alright thank you to everybody who came
out to the Wilbert theater in Boston
Massachusetts and all you [__] meth
heads and drunks who came up to the
Hukilau in Chicopee Massachusetts and my
next gig my next upcoming gig I am going
to be at wise guys in Ogden Utah
I believe it's Saturday night the
February 21st so please come out to see
me man I've never done a club out that
way I've only done colleges and why
don't you come along and bring your
eighteen [__] wives or whatever the
hell it is you Mormons do out there and
you know I figure you're a cool Mormon
if you're actually listening to so you
know come out to the show and
congratulations to the Lakers in the
Cavaliers man you guys look like you're
going to be playing you just playing a
hungrier game playing a [__] hungry
or game but
I have to say this before I sign off I
really think that the reason why I can't
stand the [__] NBA is unlike any
other sports like that that sport the
official control the outcome of the game
like I've never seen it's like it always
like the Celtics Lakers was a [__]
great game and then down into the end
they just kept blowing the whistle on
both sides I'm not being a crybaby here
Lakers won fair and square
but I'm just saying you know sometimes
they should just put the [__] whistle
away it's you know just let him [__]
play and they did that in the Cavaliers
game it's like he got these two
juggernauts going head to [__] head
and then this little fake he's blowing
his whistle now all the action stops and
then you know you know hey stop pushing
him that's ridiculous okay let's let him
shoot uncontested it's the most it's the
biggest [__] buzzkill to the end of
any game I've ever seen you know and I
love how they there's been a referee
that was has been busted for having mob
ties in the [__] NBA and I'm supposed
to act like that's the only guy like
there was y'all there was just one bad
apple you know I think I don't know what
do you guys think there's my question
for you this week out of all the four
major sports which referee do you think
if you bought them could really
influence the outs the the the outcome
of the game I'd have to go NBA because
it's so easy to get a guy out of the
game you just keep calling fouls in
football you know do you want how to
throw a guy out of the game you give
that away Tilley you know kick somebody
in the balls and spits in their face and
I don't know what look at me babbling
and you know literally the light in my
garage went out I got to get out of the
car all right guys that's it I'm gonna
save this podcast so you're gonna hear
it unless I don't know how to [__]
upload it it's gonna prove a week all
right guys take it
[Music]
alright [__] list bill I wake up at my
girlfriend's house she leaves to work I
can't find my socks she says I have some
she says I have some just use mine and
leaves I wake up later and I look for
the sock drawer top drawer right and I
find this list with about twenty to
thirty names on it and my name is near
the bottom oh no some have check marks
on them etc I asked her about it and
while she's initially upset it turns out
to be her [__] list Wow
Irina [__] I have a list in my head she
actually made a [__] list dude you
coined a phrase she said she made it
after we got together with some friends
drunk one night she then admitted to
being somewhat of a [__] her words not
mine before we met but assures me that
she hasn't done anything since she met
me with anyone else
I do believe her but I totally blew up
on her and we haven't been talking for a
few days I also look a bit creepy as to
why I went through her drawer it was in
an envelope yeah you know what it yeah
you kind of look creepy but she would
have done that to you
you know women call it snooping when we
do it it's [__] creepy anyways he
goes I need some help here on this one
do I apologize she already has do I just
say [__] it and forget about it
what's Nia's take on it god damn it you
know what I'm gonna have to
ask her take on that one I'm not gonna
have it on this podcast when I when I go
home I fly them home tomorrow I'll try
to have an epilogue to this podcast or
maybe tack it on to the following weeks
that is a great question because I don't
trust this girl you know that when a
girl is that [__] free all right
and I know girls are getting mad why
can't we be as free as you I'll tell you
why you can't because you don't have to
work at getting laid okay I can be
sexually liberated I still have to go
out to the bar I got to do a [__] tap
dance you know like me getting laid it's
it's like somebody on [__] American
Idol trying to get that ticket to Vegas
you know that's what it's like is it for
most guys anyways to get laid even if
you get good at it it's it's like
[__] you know it's it's it's not hot
but you guys any time you want to [__]
you can [__] look that girl tonight came
up with her back out I didn't know was
there I put my hand and I wasn't ready
44 year old guy I'm sitting this the
Bupa getting [__] talk um so that's
what I would be worried about she said
she's a bit of a [__] like I don't know
if that's a good thing or a bad thing or
like III don't know about that one she
sat down and she made a list Jesus name
now this is the thing I don't know how
old she is all right 20 you know for a
girl 20 to 30 names I don't think is
even that bad the fact that she but I
don't know but it might be even worse
because they they are not honest about
then they do the exact opposite of what
we do guys we exaggerate our numbers
they dial them [__]
back like like woman's how many guys
have you been with numbers is like when
they put out how many people are
unemployed in this country you know they
try to keep that number [__] down
it's the same thing a [__] list I mean I
don't know I never get past that you sat
around with your friends are your
friends all [__] you know and it's not
like they just sat there going oh yeah
you know I [__] you know Bobby fill
up [__] in Dakota tornado a [__]
modern named Range Rover whatever
[__] people call kids and boys now
and then you know this checks next to
him of like what she did with them or
how good the dick was and I I don't know
if that's one of those things that they
all [__] do and you just
unfortunately peek behind the curtain
and you should let it go I have no
experience with something like that this
would have been a great me a question I
have to do this with her and get into a
[__] giant argument but then I run
the risk of possibly getting a [__]
preview of her [__] list which I don't
want to know about I don't want to know
I mean I gotta be honest with you I
don't give a [__] at my age okay are you
clean good okay what do I think he will
[__] you know in a goddamn bubble I
hope you banged enough guys and learned
how to [__] I really do cuz I don't need
some fish in bed you know just laying
there a lot of people great isn't that
Craig do you want a pilot who hasn't
flown a lot of planes you know that does
give and take okay you got a girl hasn't
[__] a lot of guys and you know she
sucks a dick like she's eating green
beans that's the trade-off you know ah
dude that sucks that really sucks for
you why were you gonna wear one of her
socks to work though you know with
little [__] Chris Evert ball hanging
off the back
[Music]
Oh